last year you dressed as you went as the
weekend I did indeed can I tell you this
is one of the strangest experiences I've
ever had cuz I know the weekend and I
look similar from certain angles and I'm
walking downtown in New York it's
Halloween everyone is dressed up as
other things someone screams the
weekend so I go yeah that's that's the
outfit I get it then she's like can I
get a selfie the weekend then I said I'm
not the weekend she's like you're lying
I recognize
you I was like wait what so why would
the weekend be the weekend for Halloween
how does this work he wouldn't dress
what is happening right now and then she
got angry she got angry I was like I'm
not she's like don't like stop lying
just take a phone I love your I I was
like I'm not I'm not the weekend she's
like why are you being like this I was
like cuz I'm not the weekend yes of
course he's like I thought you were nice
then I'm like well I guess the weekend's
not nice I don't know what's happening
right now now you're now you're giving
him a bad name yeah so now I'm going to
go as him every year